[MUSIC]
I came to next to a patch of
black ice on a cold sidewalk
somewhere in downtown New Haven.
I was drunk, I didn't know where I was,
and felt completely lost.
The only thing I needed to do in that
moment was to sit there and start crying.
Those nights were all too common for
me in my early years of college.
The thing that I most
remember about that time
was that I just couldn't sit with myself.
I was scared.
In addition to the normal
angst of being a teenager,
I was coming to terms with the fact
that I was attracted to men.
I wanted things to be different.
I wanted to be different.
And so
I turned to whatever I could to get away.
Alcohol, drugs, and my favorite and
most acceptable distraction, work.
But no matter what I did,
inevitably I would come back
to myself,
just as I had that night in New Haven.
I woke up the next morning
with the concerned
face of a nurse hovering over
me in Yale New Haven Hospital.
When my dean caught wind of the fact that
I had drank myself into a hospital bed,
he immediately summoned
me into his office.
I was terrified.
I thought that I had blown this once in
a lifetime opportunity to go to Yale, and
that I was about to be
in a lot of trouble.
And yet,
when I walked into his office that day,
he greeted me with a big smile and a hug.
And he just started asking me questions.
Today I know that he could sense the deep
existential angst that I
was feeling at the time.
And he recommended two books for me.
One was a Christian inspired
book called Traveling Mercies.
The other was a Buddhist inspired
book called Yoga and the Quest for
the True Self.
As I carried those two books
outside of his office with me,
he quietly said, hey Vince, you might
want to check out church as well.
Life is hard.
Sometimes we find ourselves
in situations where we
are absolutely overwhelmed
by the demands of reality.
Where we can't cope.
Where the only thing we want to
do is crawl out of our own skin,
or crawl underneath a rock somewhere.
Where do we turn when
we hit the black ice?
When we fall,
how do we pick ourselves back up?
For many, the answer is religion, but for
me at the time,
that would have been quite a leap.
You see, my religion during high
school was the anti-religion.
I was a card carrying atheist, and I loved
to proving it to people around campus.
>> [LAUGH]
>> In fact, I remember one afternoon,
I got into a fight with
three Christian friends and
managed to bring all
three of them to tears,
as I poked cold holes of logic
in their Christian faith.
Now, I can't say that I'm proud of
the hurt that I caused my peers that day,
but I can say that I do
understand some of the angst
that I felt towards religion at the time.
After all, I'd been brought up
in a strict Catholic upbringing.
And have experienced some of the most
hurtful aspects of organized religion.
When I was in school,
I would get physically whipped for
not being able to recite pieces
of Scripture, or certain prayers.
When the first signs of my attraction
to men started to bubble up,
I went under the worst type of
ridicule from my friends in school.
And a much more subtle, though no less
hurtful, form of repression at home.
All grounded in the deep religious
conviction that being gay was wrong.
And that I was broken.
Yes, those tears that
afternoon in high school,
those were my revenge
against religious zealotry.
And yet, here I was,
poring again over Buddhist text and
Christian Scripture, and
actually starting to go to church again.
You see,
the pain that I was in at the time,
that feeling of dislocation,
of alienation from myself
was even worse than the pain that
religion had inflicted upon me.
It felt as if my whole world
was just swirling around me and
I just needed something
steady to grab onto.
But if I was going to go down that path
again, I was going to do it on my terms.
Instead of adhering to any one
type of religious system or dogma,
I decided to cast a wide net,
and began a spiritual journey
that took me from
Christianity to Zen Buddhism,
to Native American animism, and even
the rationalism of Enlightenment thinkers.
And over the course of that journey,
I became a sort of spiritual omnivore.
Sampling different pieces and ideas and
concepts from these religious philosophies
in order to construct my own world view.
And my own sense of meaning in the world.
Over the course of that journey,
there were three habits
that I noticed that were common across
each one of these philosophies.
That helped me pick myself back up and
I hope will be helpful for you regardless
of where you are in your journey.
The first is finding purpose
in your experiences.
Seeking out the meaning and
opportunities that can arise from even
the most challenging circumstances.
In Traveling Mercies,
the book recommended by my dean,
she talks about herself as a child of God,
learning to walk on the Earth.
And sees each relapse,
because she's a recovering alcoholic,
as an opportunity for her to get back up,
stronger than before.
Now while I couldn't quite subscribe
to the idea of God the Father, and
me as a child, I did like the idea
that the universe would put these
trials in my way as a way of
testing me and making me stronger.
And so the concept of a spiritual trial
was one that I added to my spiritual
plate.
The second idea or habit that I saw
was developing practices that
help you honor that purpose.
My first yoga instructor was a woman named
Maureen, born straight out of the 60s.
She was actually married to
Michael Bolton for a while.
Rest in peace.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Through yoga,
Maureen taught me how to listen to
the language of my body and emotions, and
taught me the power of breath to keep
myself grounded in challenging situations.
Instead of running in the way
that I had in the past,
away from these types of stressors,
today, thanks to people like Maureen,
I can hold myself in these moments,
and share space,
even at a time like today when I'm
pretty nervous, as you can imagine.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So
that was a physical practice
I added to my plate as well.
The final habit that I saw is
that of building community.
My friend Eliza and I met in a Haitian
dance class, shaking our booties,
which, by the way,
is another really fun spiritual practice.
You should try it sometime.
And since then, Eliza and I have continued
to laugh, dance and cry together.
Eliza is the type of spiritual
body that I wish everybody had.
When I fall, she helps pick me up,
when things are going all right,
she holds me accountable, and
isn't afraid to call me out on things.
In an increasingly secular society,
with all that's going on and
the increasing stress and chaos that
we find ourselves in, it's more and
more important for us to know where
to turn in those moments of duress.
And yet,
as we have an increasingly diverse and
wide array of spiritual philosophies,
the onus is increasingly on
us to make sense of our own world view and
to make our own meaning out of life.
Over the course of my journey,
I learned to put my faith in three habits.
The question that I leave with you
today is where you'll put your faith.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]